london the city of dreams abundance and
wealth they say it's a city of ease a
city of blossom a world of no struggle
taken to the hood they witness the true
trouble
i'm not worried about you bro cause
you're a good kid you got a good head on
your shoulders and guess what
listen uh habibi i just got to the
masjid is that class tonight
is that tonight
[Music]
going broke can really turn you
desperate sacrifice your honor for the
pound it can get hectic either on road
or stand or pave and spectate stay loyal
to the streets with no rules you got
checked me promise you anything good
you will
and in fact eventually the trap you have
you trapped like a bottle of attack cap
grasping for air but the money holding
you back just like a platform you got a
mind the gap between the roads in your
life could save you a lifespan
[Music]
tired of being broke
bring me in
are you sure you know what you're doing
because it's all my head is you know
[Music]
[Music]
if you want to whip like this
if you want a real money
you gotta step up your game at you
really
and if you ain't from them size you
better watch what you stan went from
playing clash of clans to the clashing
of two gangs where are you from though
bro worry about where my strong bro well
you think i run away from cuts
but i'm not feeling the explore i was
gonna have older than one road
everyone's a big man got a sherman brave
but remains cern and when they end up in
prison or in a grave
gonna do this alone
we'll go to the top
you know with mine here i'm switching
them off
hey yo
it's way too late
way too big
you thought this was a joke is that all
you had
blow your head off right now make sure
he remembers me
and make sure he remembers me
top boy i'm a leader sitting as a
creeper man reader voices in my head
like a speaker
[Music]